mais c'est vrai que ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis ça doit nous servir et de
leçons c'est de servir de leçon à toutes
les polices du monde
je vous le dis et c'est vrai que il faut
arrêter avec ces techniques
je vous le dis voilà on l'a vu ce qui
s'est passé aussi en france j'avais un
reportage poignant dans balances ton
post d'une famille aussi qui avait perdu
son papa d'une jeune fille qui avait
perdu son papa
franchement ça ça doit être je vous dis
une des priorités pour moi du
gouvernement et du ministre de
l'intérieur parce que je pense qu'on
peut faire régner l'ordre
mais voilà dans tous les pays du monde
on doit arrêter ces techniques
d'étouffement mine de rien parce que
voilà ça a été on a tous vu les images
de tous et de ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis
et franchement ces images sont
insoutenables moi je me suis en plus
renseignés sur sur ce garçon est encore
plus etc c'est vraiment joli
je pense que tout le monde se renseigne
sur ce garçon ce moment est vraiment
c'est une énorme bas venu en justice
voilà une injustice et je vous dis moi
je suis voilà je joue 10 et ça doit être
une des priorités du gouvernement parce
qu'il faut pas non plus que ça arrive en
france c'est déjà arrivé
ce que voilà on l'a vu on en a parlé
donc je vous dis j'ai eu un témoignage
très fort dans balances ton post donc
c'est vrai qu'on rigole avec afida sais
c'est un peu du second degré son
élection sa sa candidature mais c'est
vrai que là on parle de phase 2 choses
très graves
et voilà je pense qu'il va falloir qu'on
en parle qu'on en discute et que mine de
rien qu'on puisse débattre avec le
ministre de l'intérieur prochainement de
ça dans un btp ou dans une autre
émission même pas chez moi je suis pas
voilà je m'en fous ça se débattent
ailleurs mais il faut vraiment arrêter
technique voilà d'étouffement parce que
c'est c'est catastrophique et je peux
vous dire que ça va faire d'énormes
dégâts et et voilà moi je vous dis moi
j'ai été écoeuré par ce qui s'est passé
là bas aux états unis par ces images je
pense qu'on a tous été un je devais
voulait rencontrer aujourd'hui j'en
oublie je n'ai même pas fait parce que
génial j'ai pas envie c'est insoutenable
c'est passé voilà la mort d'un homme en
direct quoi c'est insoutenable jeudi en
plus bien sûr épargnants à épargner moi
qui dis je ne respire plus qui dit
arrêté et des mois arrêtés non mais
c'est insoutenable